the note 10 vs. 1 + 7 Pro debate has
been going on ever since the note 10 was
announced but today here at Mac's Tech
are we putting this comparison to a stop
with the last final video that is going
to be a real-world comparison we're not
gonna look at benchmarks respects or
anything like that well we're gonna be
talking about actual things that matter
day to day and things that will actually
make or break your purchasing decision
let's start off with the most obvious
things starting with the price the 1 + 7
Pro is an amazing value this one coming
in at $700 compared to $1100 for the
note 10 plus now that is a substantial
difference especially up front and that
alone can make or break your decision on
which bone you're gonna get now the
second one that is also very obvious is
going to be the aspirin now personally
here at Mac's sec neither redeem or I
use the s-pen very often there are some
cases like taking group photos where it
can come in very handy but as far as
actually drawing or writing notes we
don't really have a big use case for
that because we're always will on our
laptops but there's a lot of you guys
out there that have commented and let us
know that you love the S Pen and you use
it all the time so if you're somebody
that's gonna be benefiting from all the
software features packed in the note 10
then the 1 + 7 Pro cannot compete with
that in any way the next aspect of these
phones are the cut outs or lack of cut
outs the note 10 has a small cut out but
for the most part once you get used to
it you are not gonna notice it and it's
not gonna get in the way
like the notch does on the iPhone with
the 1 + 7 Pro some people worry about
the lack of a cut out resulting in this
motorized front facing camera kind of
slowing them down or maybe breaking or
water getting in or being just maybe
fragile none of that matters in the real
world because it is quick it is strong
it's sealed and it unless you like to
take selfies in a second basically it's
not gonna matter at all
so either way I don't think this makes a
difference now let's talk about two
separate features one of which is on
either one of these phones that both are
great and I wish both phones had this
but it's gonna be up to you to choose
which one is more
on the 1 plus 7 Pro I absolutely love
the physical mute and vibrate switch you
can feel it even if it's in your pocket
you can click it up to get like a silent
mode or a vibrate mode and no vibrates
so without having to look at it you can
know in which mode it's in and actually
be able to change it now on the note 10
plus we do not have that you just have
your little volume rocker but one
feature we do have is the always-on
display which I love and from the
factory you cannot have that on the 1 +
7 Pro unless you do some aftermarket
stuff so this is great when the phone is
sitting on your desk when it's wireless
charging which we'll talk about in just
a second being able to see the time the
date your battery percentage different
notifications that you may have missed
is very very handy now let's talk about
something that is absolutely brilliant
with a 1 + 7 Pro and that is the
software the software that isn't here is
not sake Android it is slightly modified
but it is better than even the software
that comes on the pixel it is fluid it
is fast it is just incredible
I love the stuff they added to it I love
the menus the launcher it is really
great the keyboard that comes with it
absolutely brilliant whereas on the note
10 the one UI is ok it's better than
before but it do still get some an
occasional kind of glitches some UI
stutters some of the software stuff
doesn't make sense I don't love the
icons so if you care about great
software go for the 1 + 7 Pro if that's
your priority it is amazing
speaking about brilliant software let me
tell you about our sponsor for this
video brilliant brilliant helps you to
excel in math and science by actually
solving problems and to learn concepts
by applying them instead of just
listening to lectures which in the real
world works much better
it's enjoyed by students professionals
in science enthusiasts all over the
world they have a wide range of content
like daily problems in math science and
computer science as well as interactive
courses from basic algebra to quantum
computing now I personally dislike
learning math because many of my classes
were boring but when I could actually
work on real-world tasks that required
math
I excelled and had a blast if that's you
as well definitely check out brilliant
we're solving problems can actually be
so fun it's addictive to support the
channel and learn more about brilliant
go to brilliant org slash max tag where
you can sign up for free and learn all
kinds of things and as a bonus for max
tech viewers the first 200 people will
also get 20% off of a premium annual
membership now one area where the 1 + 7
Pro absolutely destroys the no 10 that
is the fingerprint reader this thing is
just amazing uses optical technology so
it does have to light up the portion
that you're putting your thumb on or
whatever other finger using but it is
just so consistent it is so fast so
snappy it's just actually enjoyable to
use whereas the note 10 it is an
ultrasonic sensor so it doesn't need
light the screen doesn't have to turn on
first and do it but even with the
software updates it is still much slower
and much less consistent so at times it
is a bit frustrating where you press
down your thumb and it takes you a few
attempts to get in sometimes it works
right off the bat other times it will
take you one or two tries extra to get
in and that is frustrating now this next
one might get a little bit controversial
but I want to give you guys my honest
opinion and my real-world experience on
the displays refresh rates 90 Hertz is
definitely better but it does take more
battery and I would argue that in the
real world once you get use of the
displays it doesn't matter that much you
get used to the 90 Hertz and it is
snappy and fast but most phones are 60
Hertz and you get used to that and it is
perfectly fine it's only when you go
from one device to the other or vice
versa where you really notice that
difference and unlike competitive
gameplay going from 6 years to 9
hereit's isn't really gonna help you
like it would gone from 60 to 144 when
you're gaming now let's talk about
charging the no 10 plus comes with a
non-proprietary 25 watt charger that
actually charges the larger battery
faster by about 20 minutes than the
included warp charger that is a 30 watt
charger and is proprietary but along
with that if you're not using that
special charger a lot of people have
issues
even get 15 watts but instead get 7.5
watts instead of 25 that's because the
1.7 Pro is quite picky with which
adapter you use with which cable you use
and also a different software that is on
the phone that sometimes gives you
really slow charging speeds and on top
of that with the no 10 plus we have both
15 watt fast wireless charging and also
reverse wireless charging which for me
personally makes a big difference since
I could set the phone on the charger
during my work day and always have it
topped off and along with that comes
battery life because of the 90 Hertz
screen and the smaller battery inside of
the oneplus 7 pro the battery life is
quite a bit worse I get around one and a
half hours of more a screen on time with
heavy use with the note 10 and that
means even though we have super fast
charging we're wireless charging I don't
really need it because it can actually
get me through a full day whereas with
the oneplus 7 pro I do have to top off
just like with my iPhone 10 s max now
let's jump right back to the displays
and talk about brightness where the note
10 plus gets up to 1200 nits in the Sun
if you have it in the auto mode which
makes it much more viewable outside
compared to the 1 plus 7 Pro now both
these screens are OLED they're made by
Samsung but this one is definitely a
step above and if you like watching
videos playing back HDR looks fantastic
on here especially in 1440p whereas the
1 + 7 Pro does not get as bright the
highlights are quite a bit dimmer and
it's a little bit more flat even in the
vivid mode so as far as watching videos
the note m+ is definitely a step above
now next we can go into the speakers and
if you're watching videos the speakers
are definitely better on the note 10
[Music]
both of them are usable but in certain
situations in the real world if you're
in a noisy environment say at a
restaurant if you're out somewhere with
friends and you're wanting to share a
funny video or something cool that you
found a lot of times with the 1 plus 7
throw it is just too quiet just like my
iPhone it's actually quieter than the
iPhones whereas the note 10 plus it has
the extra volume and that definitely
helps out in those certain situations
now the last thing that I want to talk
about and this is a huge one that is
cameras the note 10 plus is definitely a
huge step ahead in photo quality now the
1 plus 7 pro for the price is quite good
but it is inconsistent sometimes it's
overexposed underexposed to warm to cool
all those kind of things you can get
great photos but it is a lot more
limited and a lot more inconsistent
whereas Samsung has made some fantastic
improvements with photo quality it's
very consistent and they unlock certain
things like being able to do a panorama
with the standard or the wide angle or
being able to use night mode with either
the front-facing camera or any of the
three rear-facing cameras to get great
quality nighttime photos whereas with
the oneplus you can only use that
standard camera so there you guys have
it that is my real-world comparison
between the oneplus 7 pro and the Galaxy
Note 10 and the note 10 definitely is a
cut above the oneplus 7 pro if you can
afford it definitely that would be my
suggestion but if you're somebody that
really just cares about having a large
screen and really good software that's
quick
that's snappy that doesn't slow down a
good fingerprint reader so that you can
just get in and do your task quick you
don't care about things like having
crazy battery life better photos better
speakers things like that the oneplus 7
pro is still an amazing value let me
know your thoughts down in the comments
section below once again a huge shout
out to brilliant for sponsoring this
video please use the link down below and
go and check them out this has been max
with max tech if you guys want to see
more videos like this we have a couple
right over there and you guys can
subscribe and enable notifications below
to see more videos we have a lot of
other cool videos coming up you guys
could do that thanks for watching and
I'll see you in the next video
[Music]